meg the stallion on new music and her
girl power bond with beyonce
and cardi b certified free cardi is like
seven days my home girl i don't cook i
don't clean but
to be two women with big personalities
and big confidence and still be able to
co-exist comfortably with each other
like that is like a really big deal to
me like i really respect her
oh she's so bougie bougie beyonce is
somebody that is just
so top tier so you just feel so great to
know that you've even made it to where
you can be in a room with beyonce
like i'm like girls breathing beyonce
air that is a flex
so who will megan collaborate with next
she's keeping that a secret until her
album drops on friday
debut studio album what does that feel
like for you
i titled the good news because yes we've
been having an extremely crazy year and
what felt like we were getting bad news
back to back like i thought
megan no stallion needs to drop some
good news college girl but a freak on
the weekend
a few things to know about meg four
months after she was shot in the foot
twice at a hollywood party
she's moving on currently doing the no
alcohol no sugar challenge
she wants to open assisted living
facilities and the 25 year old is
studying health administration in
college
why is it so important for you to get a
college degree
my grandmother was a teacher when my
mother was still alive
she definitely was pushing me to finish
college so
i'm definitely going to do it for those
two i'm projected to graduate 2021
i'll be damned if i don't get this
degree meg is also dropping a fashion
nova collection
on wednesday being a curvy woman
especially a curvy woman of color i have
always found it a little difficult
to go into like a more designer store
and find something that fits to my body
so if i can put my hand
in a healthy pot then that's what i
wanted to do